Hello everyone.
Welcome to my
lecture. Today
we're going to talk
about the general
sensory systems.
In this hour we're
going to talk about
the somatosensory
system including the
detailed receptors
and their encoding.
We're going to cover
in more details about
the pathways you
know for touch and
proprioception as well
as pain and temperature.
So you know these
are So we're going to
cover from the
peripheral, you know,
the receptors and up
all the way to our
cerebral cortex,
this entire pathway.
We will talk about
the lesions as well
as their clinical
symptoms relevance.
Please make sure
you read the
detailed objectives
in the CPG as
well as the
scholarly research.
brick. Back to the
Comlex blueprint,
we can see that the
sensory disturbances
and pain is a
pretty important
chapter of the
blueprint. So it's
including tactile
disturbances, as well
as, you know,
vibration, temperature,
proper suction, as
well as all sorts of
pain, you know, chronic
and neuropathic.
So make sure you really
study hard for
this section.
In the USMLE blueprint,
very similar.
So you see the
different types of
sensory modalities
being covered,
as well as the
abnormal processes,
including different
types of pain syndromes,
you know, a long
list of things.
There are different
sizes, sheath,
and speed of the
afferent fibers.
Showing here, as
you can see from
left to right,
you know, you
have different
types of fibers,
and so they have
different characteristics.
First of all, I'd like
to point your attention
to, you know, different
diameters. You
can see here, this one
is very large diameter
versus this, the
smallest one, you know,
the C fiber, right, has
a small, much smaller
diameter. And also
these purple aspects,
these are myelin sheets.
And so the different
thickness of myelin
sheets, as you can see,
you know, from left
to right, you know,
getting smaller and
smaller. And then you also
have the C fibers
that's kind of unique.
It does not have any
myelin sheets. So these
are C fibers are called
unmyelinated fibers
and you know the difference
among these setup
is actually made at
the conduction velocity
so when you have
increased diameter and
increase the thickness
of myelin sheath you're
going to have increased
conduction velocity
so for these fibers as
you can see you know
these alpha motor
neurons will conduct a
lot faster compared to
the c fibers you know
myelinated fibers and
their speed can be you
know about 100 fold
difference among different
fibers based on the
conduction velocity
as well as the axon
diameters we could divide
these peripheral fibers
into myelinated and
unmyelinated fibers as
you can see here you
know on the left you
have the fastest fibers
on the right you have
the slowest fibers
and it's correlated with
the diameters you know
so largest diameters
on the left will have
the fastest velocity
so those two parameters
are connected very
closely and there are
two different way of
categorizing these fibers
you can see here
the a fibers are the
myelinated fibers and
then the c fibers are
unmyelinated fibers and
then you know these are
correlating with different
types of a fibers
like a alpha would be
the largest diameter
you know compared to
the c fibers so you have
type a fibers that's
correlating to a alpha
and then you have
type 4 fibers that's
correlating to the c
fibers so you don't have to
remember the axonal
diameter kind of
categorization but
i'd like you to
at least remember
the a and c these
fiber division systems
okay so here are the
fibers you need to
remember for the myelinated
fibers we have a and
then for unmyelinated
fibers we have C and
under this A myelinated
fibers we also have
fastest A-alpha fibers
that's mediating the
proprioception as well
as the motor function
if you recall at the
spinal cord ventral
horn there are alpha
motor neurons those are
these type with alpha
fiber these neurons has
the largest diameter
thickest myelin sheath
so they're conduct
conducting the fastest.
And A-beta fibers
are for the touch
fibers. So when we are
talking about DCML,
touch and
proprioception, they're
alpha and A-beta
fibers, so largest
diameter fibers for
the DCML pathway.
For the pain and
temperature pathway,
dull pain and temperature
are mediated by
the C fibers and i want
to point out one more
thing for the sharp pain
so you know initially
when we feel something
real fast those
kind of sharp pain is
actually mediated by
fast conducting fibers
a delta fibers they're
not as fast as the
touch fibers but they
are thinly myelinated
they're still significantly
faster than the c
fibers the c fibers
also mediating itch
and also postganglionic
autonomic neurons
if you remember the
autonomics we talked about
the gray remus and the
white remus so you
know the gray remus is
these non-myelinated
postganglionic neurons
and then for the
preganglionic fibers they're
actually b fibers so
this is the one that
we haven't really
talked about before but
you need to remember
that b fiber is the pre
-ganglionic autonomic
fibers for visceral
sensation showing here if
you record from a nerve
that you know the
electrical change you
know the voltage change
from the nerve you
would be able to see
these the different types
of fiber and then forming
different waveforms
so if we gave a strong
electrical stimulus
to the skin so it's
like an electrical shock
to the skin then
you're going to be able
to record three different
forms you can see
the fastest one you
know the initial peak
comes in very large peak
these are mediated by
the a alpha a beta
fibers for touch and per
perception and then
you know shortly after
that you're going to see
the second peak these
are the a delta fiber
mediated still fairly
fast and you know
then you see the third
third wave you
know much smaller
magnitude and
was a very long
delay so that's
c fiber mediated
so if you imagine you
know when we're receiving
some electrical
shock you would feel
something real sharp
you know it's like a pin
prick and then you just
withdraw your arm for
example then uh that's
the uh fastest fiber
mediated by the a delta
fiber that type of
pain and then after that
you're going to realize
oh it's a bit burning
at the skin surface
too so those would
be mediated by the c
fiber so faster for the
sharp pain with a delta
and then slower with
c fiber that would be
the dull pain and then
different types of
fibers mediating different
sensory modalities
now let's talk about
the diversity of
the receptors for
the somatosensation
by receptors i mean
the initial very
beginning of the sensory
apparatus so we talked
about the fibers
earlier right so those
are either large or
smaller diameter fibers
have the neurons you
know with the cell
body and then sending
the axons on both
ends you know peripheral
and central end
so the receptors
would be the ones the
apparatus that are located
at the initial part
of these peripheral
sensory fibers these
apparatus can sense
different types of
sensory modalities you
something in the eyes
like rods and cones
would be different from
the hair cells and
then would be different
from the skin right
so you would have
all sorts of apparatus
to sense different
types of sensory
information so we're going
to talk about them
individually in the
following slides or
lectures and you just need
to know them in general
for this lecture
we can categorize
different receptors by
their source or
their the types of
stimuli so the source
of stimuli kind of give
us the three different
categories of
receptors they're
called intero receptors
extero receptors and
proprioceptors so
you can kind of you
know figure out the
meaning by the
name, interoceptors
receiving the internal
stimuli generated within
the same, you know,
within our body.
For example, the bio
-receptors that we
mentioned in our autonomic
lectures, so it's
sensing the blood
pressure, you know, the
change, the stretch
of the smooth muscles,
and those internal
stimuli will
activate the
interoceptors.
Exteroceptors are
the general receptors
that we had in mind
right when we are sitting
on something when we're
touching something
those receptors are
activated so exterior
receptors are the
general ones that we
are all familiar with
probe receptors are
the ones that sensing
the change of the body
positions like
receptors that joins you
know they're kind of
special based on the
types of stimuli there
are chemo receptors
photoreceptors,
thermal receptors,
mechanoreceptors. Based on
the name, you can figure
out what are the sensory
information they are
activated by. So
another special one that
I want to mention is
called nociceptors. So
nociceptors is not
limited to individual
stimulus, but it's actually
any kind of a stimulus
that are reaching the
harmful or hurting
level. So when there's
high intensity, either
mechanical, thermal,
chemical, whatever,
that can produce
harm, then these
non-succeptors
would be activated.
Okay, let's look
at the different
types of sensory sensors.
First, let's look at
the touch sensors.
We call it touch.
It's actually a little
wider than touch.
It's more accurately
being expressed as
exteroceptors because
they are sensing the
external stimuli,
also called
mechanoreceptors.
All kinds of mechanical
stimuli, such as
touch and pressure,
vibration, they're
all included in this
type of receptors.
There are four
different kinds that I
want to highlight. So
Meissner's corpuscles,
you can see different
morphology from
the Merkle disk and
also the proscenium
corpuscle and ruffini
endings. They all
have a different kind
of morphology at the
end. So let's look
at their functions.
Okay, let's look
at the touch
receptors in
more details.
As you can see here
for the receptors,
you have something
like shallower, like
Meissner's corpuscle
and Merkel cells. You
also have the several
different kinds
that are deeper in
the skin away from the
surface of the
skin. So there are
proscenium's corpuscle
and Ruffini's endings.
So, you know, based
on the position, you
can kind of imagine,
you know, these
at the surface, they're
mediating touch.
you know like light
touch and fine touch
discriminative and so
they require smaller
receptive field
right so the receptor
receptive field for these
surface receptors are
much smaller and
fine-tuning you know
higher resolution compared
to these uh pursinance
corpuscle or ruffini
endings they have
much larger receptive
field and because
they're mediating
vibration and pressure
they don't really require
that high resolution
the fine-tuning of
the sensory modality
and and then for
each small or large
receptive field receptors
you would have fast
adapting and slow
adapting differences
so meissner's corpuscle
is fast adapting
you can see when you
record you know when
the stimulus is applied
you have a train
of action potential
and it stops quickly.
Versus with the
slow adapting the
Merkle cells, after
you give the stimulus,
you're going to
see a train of
action potentials,
you know, slowly
slowing down. That's
the slow adapting.
And similarly for
the proscenium
corpuscle, it's
much, you know,
like a quicker have
the action potentials,
then it disappears. Versus
the Ruffini endings,
you would have a train
of action potentials
slow adapting how
do you remember this
you can kind of remember
them by you know
alphabetical order so m
and m those are smaller
receptive field and
then you know p and
r you know later ones
deeper they have the
large receptive field
and then uh you know
it's also alphabetical
cmei versus mer right
so those are the fast
versus slow adapting
receptors and p
is a fast adapting
large receptive
field and r is slow
adapting large receptive
field so hopefully
that helps you
to remember these
and the two-point
discrimination has
been used for uh
determining the touch
sensitivity you
know the receptive
field as you can
see here you know
it's basically using
the two stimuli
applied at a certain
distance and ask the
experimenter you know are
you able to tell these
are two different
dots and then if they
can then you just keep
shrinking those distance
between the two points
until they couldn't
tell whether it's one
or two and that would
be the receptive field
for that area so as
you can see here our
fingers has a much
smaller receptive field
compared to our back you
know you have a much
larger receptive field
for the touch sensation
and so why is that
this actually reflects
the density of those
touch receptors so when
you have the packed
highest that would be
at the fingertips right
it makes sense that
during the daily life
we need a much finer
sensation you know be
able to tell what are
the different things
touching our skin at
our fingertips compared
to at the back you know
you don't usually need
to use the back too
much in terms of you
know sensing those
stimuli so you know these
are areas that need it
the most has the most
density of the touch
receptors to help
provide that high resolution
small receptor field
now let's look at the
pro-perceptors these
are the special receptors
that are transmitting
the properception
information. As you
can see here, when the
muscle spindle fires,
you know, showing here in
the red rectangle here,
when the muscle spindle
fires, you know,
so showing the
contraction of the muscle,
then the gorgy tendon
organ that's located
at the edge of the
muscle spindle would
be able to fire
and transmit the
information about the
lens of the contraction
of the muscle fiber
and the contraction.
And the joint
receptors are also able
to fire if there is
a change of the angle
of this joint. And
so basically the
joint receptor is able
to sense the large
degree of the
extension of the joint.
How do tendon organs
sense the force at
the tendon? You can
see here these are
kind of yellowish
gold color these are
the golgi tendon
organs and they are the
free nerve endings
kind of winding
through the collagen
and then you know
showing here an enlarged
image like these
are the golgi tendon
organs they sense
the pulling force at
the junction joint
receptors are
sensitive to the angle
of the joint and
they're insensitive
when the joint is
in normal range. You
know, for example,
here at 100 degrees,
there is barely no
firing at all in this in
these joint receptors.
And when there's
extremes and or
inappropriate directions,
you know, for example,
For example, when the
degree become 140 or
when there's maximum
extension, then the
firing goes crazy. So
that's the feature of
the joint receptors.
We mentioned that
nociceptors are special,
so they are actually
responding to all
kinds of stimuli as
long as the intensity
of the stimuli are
beyond the normal range.
you know when it's
potentially producing
harm that's when
nociceptor is firing.
You can see here there
is two types right
you have the first pain
and then you have the
second pain so the you
know this is happening
the first pain happens
immediately and
then the second pain
has a long delay and
then it has a long
lasting painful sensation.
So these are mediated
by two different fibers
so a delta fiber is the
one that uh remember
it's thinly myelinated
so transmitting
faster and it's uh you
know giving us that
first pain and the c
fibers are the slower
unmyelinated fibers
that give us that slower
second pain uh give you
a classic example so
for example when we're
touching a hot stove
and so your fingers are
you know immediately
quickly sensing that
sharp pain and that would
be mediated by these
A-delta fibers and
this sharp pain is
actually, you know, lead
to the spinal reflex.
So you're withdrawing
your finger immediately
before you even realize,
you know, there's a
pain and then you just
kind of have that fast
response within the
spinal cord and then
you realize oh it hurts
and then later on
after that fast pain
dissipated you're going
to experience some slower
pain you know it's
kind of a dull aching
and you know it lasts
for a long time even
during the development
of the blister So that's
our second pain mediated
by the C fibers.
We all have those sense
that when you have
something like, you know,
when a nurse injecting
the vaccine to your
arm, they kind of rub
the surroundings to
help reduce that pain.
So the principle is
that when you have the
touch neurons activating
an interneuron here,
it will be able to
inhibit these projection
neurons that transmitting
the painful sensation
from the C-fiber.
So basically, this
projection neuron is
activated by the C-fiber
but inhibited by the
interneuron that's being
activated by the touch
sensation. Therefore,
the total or the
sum of the signal is
reduced. So you have a
reduced activation of the
projection neurons for
the painful signal.
Now the pain responses
are really tightly
modulated by the
descending structures.
For example, midbrain,
palms, medulla,
they all have the
projection neurons
sending down to the
spinal cord. We'll go
over that in the next
slide. We talked about
midbrain PAG, peri
-acredactyl gray, is
able to activate the
LC as well as the
raffi-magnus to
release norepinephrine
and serotonin to
inhibit the spinal cord,
modulate the spinal
cord projecting
neurons for the painful
sensation. So it
produces profound
inhibition of the pain.
You can see here
encephaline being released
by these projections
from the PAG,
LC, or RAFI, and
release the encephaline
of the interneurons
in the spinal cord.
And that's why when
the nauseous sector
is being activated
here, the projecting
neurons are receiving
both inhibitory
input from these
interneurons and the
activation of the
primary ather neurons.
I'd like to talk a
little bit about itch.
So itch sensation is
also mediated by the
C fibers. It's
different from pain, but
it's mediated by the
C fibers as well.
And why that scratching
can help reduce
the painful response,
I mean the itchy.
And we actually have
the similar type of
theory that the pain
inhibits itch, just
like touch inhibits
pain. So with the
collateral interneurons
that produce
inhibitory signals, this
is similar as a gate
theory as we talked
about previously.
So the itch can be
either histamine
sensitive or
histamine independent.
The histamine
independent type
of itch is very
hard to treat.
Okay, now let's summarize
our sensory receptors.
Pause the video,
give yourself a
few minutes to fill
in these blanks.
And here's the
answer. Hopefully
you got them
all correctly.
okay let's do
some practice
questions see if
you can solve this
question pause
the video here
and here's the answer
hopefully you
got it right
okay we've covered
the sensory receptors
and the fibers in the
periphery now let's
go back and then
look at the entire
pathway the ascending
sensory pathways now
do you guys remember
what are the you
know dcml and spinothalamic
tracts mediating
what kind of signals
do they transmit
so the answer is the
dcml is transmitting
the touch and proprioception
and spinothalamic
tract is mediating
pain and temperature
sensation so these are
different sensations
have a commonality so
as you can see here
you know drawing
there are three neuron
relays so you have this
first order neurons
at the peripheral
and then sending the
information into the spinal
cord then it's a sent
to synapse at the
secondary order neurons
in this case in the
DCML case the secondary
order neurons is
located in medulla and
then they will ascend
again to the thalamus
to meet with the third
order neurons and
then the thalamus you
know neurons will go
ahead and and go to the
somatocentric cortex
which can be considered
the fourth neuron
but usually we just
say the relay takes
three neurons and
if you put together
what fiber we you know
mediate in this pathway
if you remember our
touch and proprioception
has these uh large
diameter a alpha
or a beta fibers right
to mediating touch
and proprioception
they're large diameter
heavily myelinated
fibers and then on the
receptor side uh they
have the you know very
specialized the that's
a meissner corpuscle
miracle cells and
so on so that's the
receptor and the special
fiber that's coming
in and then for the
spinostalamic tract
you also have this
primary aferring neurons
coming from the periphery
and then synapse
right away to the
secondary order neurons
in the spinal cord
and then again it has
a third order neuron
in the thalamus you
know to be more
specific that would be
the the vpl right for
the body and then it
reached the somatosensory
cortex neurons
we can either call it
force neuron or you
know just kind of
know it's the neurons
in the somatosensory
cortex that gave us
that final sensation
so in this case for
the pain and temperature
sensation the
primary A-fair neuron
would be that C fiber,
right? The
slow conducting
unmyelinated fibers,
or the fast pain
is mediated by
the A-delta fiber,
which is a thinly
myelinated kind of
fast conducting,
but still slower
compared to the A
-alpha and A-beta fibers
for the DCML pathway.
All right.
So here is a
primary afferent.
That's our first
order neuron.
And remember, we
talked about the cell
bodies of those first
order neurons is
located at the dorsal
root ganglia DRGs.
These DRG neurons
has a special
name called pseudo
unipolar neurons.
The reason that they
are pseudo unipolar
because it looks like
bipolar. You know,
they look like two
branches of axons.
In fact, this is
pseudo-unipolar because
they only have one
axon that, you know,
from the cell body
sent out to the central
terminal, to the
spinal dorsal horn.
So this peripheral
afferent
fiber is actually
not an axon.
That's why it's called
pseudo-unipolar. and
so these axons you
know comes into the
dorsal horn of the spinal
cord if there's any
damage to these pathway
you know for the
primary afferent then you
would have ipsilateral
deficit for the for
the sensation the
secondary order neurons
sending the axons
out and always the
secondary order neurons
are having the
decosition so if you
recall we talked about
the secondary order
neurons for the
pain and temperature
sensation is located
right at the spinal
cord dorsal horn and
then it passed the
midline through the
anterior white commissure
and joined the spinal
thalamic tract.
For the touch and
proprioception, you have
the receptors
ascending isolaterally
without synapsing to
the secondary order
neurons until reaching
medulla. and when it
reached the medulla
it will synapse at
the two nuclei at the
medulla level and then
use the DCML the
medial laminiscus part
so this is the dorsal
column part within
the spinal cord the
medial laminiscus is
passing the midline
to the other side and
then the signal goes
up to the thalamus
the damage at the
spinal level for these
two different tracks
are causing two
different lateralizations
of deficit
as we talked about in
the spinal collector
it's the lateral
loss of touch and
perception and then
contralateral loss
of pain and temperature
sensation and
so But when you have
the damage that's
above the decosition,
right here,
above the medulla
level, then all of
these areas would
generate the
contralateral loss
of both sensations.
Now let's go through
these special sensory
pathways one by one
in great details.
The first one is
spinothalamic pathway.
Spinal salamic pathway is
transmitting the
pain and temperature
information
and also itch.
So here I put a stop
sign for the facial or
cephalic information,
so you can ignore
that at this point.
We're just going to talk
about the body
somatosensory information.
So here the primary
afferent has their cell
body located in the
dorsal root ganglion,
or DRG. so the signals
coming from the
peripheral reach the
cell body and the
central terminal of
this sensor neuron will
synapse at the dorsal
horn and you know to
send the signal to
the secondary order
neurons the secondary
order neurons uh remember
we talked about
they are passing the
baseline passing
the midline make the
decosition so these
order neurons passing the
anterior y commissure
to reach the spinal
thalamic tract so
this spinal thalamic
tract is now formed on
the contraladder side
of where the input
initial sensory input
coming coming in so
this spinal thalamic
tract goes all the
way up to the thalamus
do you remember which
nucleus that for the
body sensation for the
spinal from the body
in the thalamus so here
it's actually called
vpl right so vpl is
for the body sensation
and now reach the
third-order neurons, so
synapse at the third
-order neurons. And these
neurons will send the
axons out to the fourth
neuron at the primary
somatosensory cortex.
So this pathway is using
the internal capsule.
To be specific, it's
a posterior limb
of the internal
capsule to reach the
primary somatosensory
cortex. So because
of the decusation
happens very early
on at the spinal
level, therefore, the
damage to the
spinothalamic tract almost
always cause
contralateral deficit.
For the DC-ML pathway,
so DC is dorsal
column, ML is medial
lamniscus, it's because
of the true part of
this pathway. So the
primary atheric
neurons again comes in,
you know, bring the
peripheral information
for touch and for
perception to the
spinal cord. It does
not synapse, but instead
it's going up all the
way to the medulla,
brainstem medulla,
and synapse here to
the secondary order
neurons located at
the nucleus gracilis
or nucleus cuneatus.
The two nuclei is
separated because
the nucleus gracilis
is receiving
information from
the lower body.
as you can see here
and the cuneated the
nucleus cuneatus is
receiving information
from the upper body
so this is part of
the fasciculus cuneatus
that uh receiving
the information from
the upper body and
now you can see the
cervical spinal cord
dorsal column has two
parts the fasciculus
cuneatus and the
fasciculus gracilis.
So this is a
dorsal column.
And then after it
passed the secondary
order neurons,
sending out the axons
across the midline,
remember, secondary
order neurons is a
one-decosate, right?
So this neuron passed
the midline and
formed the medial
lemniscus pathway.
Now it goes all the
way up to the thalamus.
Again, the thalamic
nuclei that's
in charge of the body
sensation is VPL.
So it synapses here
to the third-order
neurons in the thalamus,
and the thalamus sends
out the axon to the
somatosensory cortex,
that's the fourth
neuron there, to have
the sensation for the
touch and perception,
again, via the internal
capsule posterior limb.
So if we have damage
at the spinal cord
level, then you would
have the deficit
that's in the
ipsilateral side of
the body with a
touch and perception.
But if you have
damage above the
medulla, then
the deficit would
be on the
contralateral side.
Let's talk about the
facial sensation.
So on the face,
there are the main
sensory fibers are
trigeminal nerve,
right? The cranial
nerve five. And so
there are three sensory
trigeminal nuclei
and one trigeminal
motor nucleus.
So there are a total
of four trigeminal
nuclei. And among these
three nuclei, you have
the principal or main
or pontine, these are
the same things, you
know, different names.
These trigeminal
nucleus is located at
pons. It's for the touch
and proprioception.
And this is equivalent
of the dorsal column
nuclei for the DCML
pathways. So those
are the nucleus gracilis
and nucleus cuneatus,
right, located at
the dorsal medulla.
and so the pain and
temperature signal is
transmitted by the
spinal trigeminal nucleus
it's called spinal
trigeminal because
it actually extended
you know from the
medulla all the way
down to the cervical
spinal cord so but
main portion is
located in the medulla
so this says This
nucleus is equivalent
to the center or
the neurons as the
spinal cord nucleus
appropriate for the
spinothalamic tract.
And so they receive
the non-susceptive
signals, you
know, pain signals
as well as temperature
information.
The third one is a
special sensory nucleus.
It's called mesencephalic.
Methencephalic
meaning midbrain,
right? So this nucleus
is located in the
midbrain. What makes
it so special is that
these are actually
the first order
neurons. So they're kind
of part of the trigeminal
ganglion neurons
that's supposed to
be in the peripheral,
but is now
located inside the
central nervous system
inside midbrain.
So it's equivalent of the
DRGs in the spinal cord.
It has a special
purpose, mainly just
transmitting the
proprioception of the
jaw muscles and
periodontal regions.
And so these sensory
fibers through the
trigeminal nerve
coming in, you know,
without synapsing at the
pulse level, but just
coming up to the
midbrain and, you know,
the cell body is
located in the
mesencephalic trigeminal
nucleus. and then so
these trigeminal nerve
you know coming in
with our mesencephalic
trigeminal nucleus
cell bodies and
then send out axons
to synapse at the
trigeminal motor
nucleus to form
this jaw **** reflex
so this trigeminal
motor nucleus
comes back to the
jaw to produce that
muscle contraction
and relaxation the
whole purpose of this
jaw **** reflex is to
reduce the damage
potential damage
to the teeth when
we chew so this
jaw **** reflex
it's kind of a
small function but
it's very useful
okay let's talk
about the detailed
pathways for the
trigeminal system
The first one, pontine
trigeminal pathway.
This is to convey
the touch and
proprioception for
the head and face.
And so it's similar
to the DCML for
the body, but slightly
different route.
Let's go through
this. So it also has
the first order neuron
or primary afferent
neuron has a cell
body located in a
ganglion called the
trigeminal ganglion.
Just very similar
to the dorsal
root ganglion
for the body.
So trigeminal ganglion
has the cell bodies,
and those are pseudo
-unipolar neurons, right?
Send the primary
afferent to the pons.
You guys remember the
cranial nerve, right?
Trigeminal nerve is
at the pons. And then
enters the pons, synapse
to the secondary order
neuron here at the
principal or pontine
trigeminal nucleus.
And so these secondary
-order neurons, remember
for the sensory ascending
pathways, the
secondary-order neurons
are the ones sending out
the axon and decasite,
right? So they cross
the midline, goes to
the contralateral
side, and then ascend
from there. So these
ascending paths in the
midline, passing the
midbrain, reaching thalamus
through trigeminal
laminiscus. and here
at the thalamus we'll
see that to the third
order neurons and do
you remember where
exactly in the thalamus
we have these third
order neurons for the
face and if you don't
remember here is the
answer right the VPM so
very pretty makeup that
is for the face and
head sensation in
thalamus so from vpm it
will send the axons you
know from third order
neural axons ascending
up again you remember
the pathway here it's
an internal capsule
specifically it would
be the posterior limb
of the internal capsule
so along the internal
capsule it will
reach the primary
somatosensory cortex which
is located at the post
central gyrus right and
here it will synapse
with the cortex
cortical neurons to have
our conscious and
sensation of the face
sometimes it's called
force neurons but rarely
people refer that okay
so now let's look at
the lesions so i want
to mention specifically
about medulla lesion
because it's special
here you can you can
think about you know,
alongside this
pathway, it's
at the pontine
level, right?
Pontine or above.
So if you have the
lesion below the
pounds, then you
would not have the
deficit for the
touch and
proprioception for face,
right? And what
about for the body?
So for the body, you
know, the DCML pathway
already cross the
midline so now would be
contralateral deficits
for the body right if
you have the at medulla
level so that's a
unique um characteristics
right you have the
contralateral body
touch and proprioception
deficit but without
the facial or head
deficits for the touch
and proprioception let's
look at the spinal
trigeminal pathway This
pathway is even more
special than the pontine
trigeminal pathway because,
you know, initially
when the trigeminal
ganglion sends the
signals, these pseudo
-unipolar neurons send
the signals through
the pons, right? That's
where the trigeminal
nurse enters the brain.
So instead of a synapse
here, it actually
going down along the
latter side of the palms
and medulla to reach
the spinal trigeminal
nucleus. And here
it's synapse to send
the signal to the
secondary order neurons.
And, you know, these
spinal trigeminal
nucleus axons will
cross the midline
and then going
along, going back to
the pons, going across
the midbrain and,
you know, all the
way to the thalamus
via the trigeminal
thalamic tract.
And so here it
synapses to the third
order neurons, which
located again at
the VPM for the
face, right? And then
these neurons will
send axons to the
somatosentric cortex
via the internal
capsule. So again,
it's posterior limb.
So this pathway, you
can imagine it's, you
know, starting coming
into the pons, but
then coming down to the
medulla. So now if you
have a lesion at the
mid-pons level, So
you're going to have
ipsilateral damage for
the touch and proprioception,
you know, which
will be synapsing
here at the mid-pounds
level. But then you're
going to have the
contralateral deficit
for the pain and
temperature because those
fibers already cross
the midline and then
decasited, right? so it's
a lateral for the
touch and contralateral
for the pain for the
facial sensations so
it's very special type
of presentation now
let's look at the
fourth order neuron in
the primaries of
metasensory cortex at the
post central gyrus so
there is a homunculus
sensory homunculus
meaning it's a small human
that's shown here.
You can see, you know,
the foot is at the
midline of this post
central gyrus and then
it comes in a little
bit more lateral is
the leg and then trunk
and then, you
know, on the way
lateral side
you have this
big representation
of the hand
as well as a very
big representation
of the face on
the very lateral
side. So this
is a small human
distribution. You
need to remember it.
Mainly the leg
is more medial,
and then trunk,
and then hand and
face, and then
the aural borings.
All right, now we've
learned the entire
somatosensory pathways
from the body and the
face. You should be
able to start from
the receptors and then
go through different
nuclei and then thalamus
and then cortex.
Now fill in this
pathways yourself.
Now here's the
answer. So hopefully
you were able to
draw those all out.
Here I'd like to
mention that, you know,
the body for the touch,
you have thalamus
VPL nucleus
mediating these touch
sensation of the body
as well as for the pain.
So both of them are
VPL for the body
and they reach the
somatosensory cortex.
I have two additional
pathways here, you
know, from the for
the pain pathways.
so you have these
vpm even for the body
vpm and medial
dorsal medial nucleus
these are reaching
insula and the cingulate
cortex this is
for the affective
component of the pain
affective component
meaning the unpleasantness
of pain sensation
so similar for the
face you have the two
uh you know two
pathways to reach these
uh limbic structures
to mediating
unpleasantness of pain
sensation uh so shown here
you know why do we
feel the painful
response are not pleasant
right why they are
unpleasant is because
of those two burn
areas that being
innervated by like the
signals being sent
to those brain areas.
If you remember,
I mentioned in
our limbic
structure lecture,
if we do the
singulotomy, so if
we damage the
cingulate cortex,
then the person would
not be bothered by
the painful response,
but they could
still tell, okay,
this is the painful
stimuli, but I don't
care anymore, so it
doesn't bother me anymore.
Basically, largely
removed the affective
component or
unpleasantness of this
painful sensation.
Another special
phenomenon
called the phantoms
of the body.
The phantoms usually
come from all
of a sudden the
loose or removal
of the body part,
usually extremities,
due to surgery
or accident.
this type of sensation
is related to
that last body part
that you still feel
like being touched
it still exists in
your brain and a lot
of times these uh
sensations are
painful so it's called
phantom limb pain
and the phantom limb
pain is quite resistant
to medications
The cause of it is
not super clear.
Current hypothesis
is that the cortical
representation of this
last extremity takes
time to be reorganized.
And, you know,
it takes time for
the brain to learn
that that limb is
not existing anymore.
Down here, you can
see a gentleman with
a mirror trying to
fool the brain to
say, OK, even if he
lost the right limb,
but his unheard you
know the left leg is
still there and
looking at looking into
the mirror it's
telling the his brain
okay my right leg is
still okay and that
can usually diminish
the phantom limb pain.
It's a pretty strange
phenomenon but
you know basically
you're trying to fold
the brain again to
ease up that painful
experience. Fortunately
the phantom limb
pain diminishes over time
and these are the
review for the most part
you know how do we
think about whether it's
ipsilateral or
contralateral deficit when
you have a lesion or
conversely you know
when you have a deficit
which side of the
body which side of
the nervous system is
lesioned so you need to
be able to figure that
out by now once we
went through all of
these pathways. And
remember the general
rule, when we have lesions
above the decussition,
it costs a contralateral
deficit. When
we have the lesions
below the decussition,
then it will cause
ipsilateral deficits.
If you don't remember
this part, go
back to our spinal
cord lecture, please.
Now test yourself if
we have an injury at
the, you know, specific
levels here, then
what exactly side of
the deficit you're
going to see. Make sure
you differentiate both
body and the head.
Okay, so the body and
head may be different
in terms of which
specific level for this
different neuraxis.
And here's the answer.
I'd like to emphasize
or explain a little
bit more about the
pontine lesions that
related to the pain and
temperature sensation.
As you can understand
that the contralateral
body, this makes
sense. For the
face, I put both ipsi
and contralateral
deficits if we have
lesions at the pons.
This is due to if
we have the pontine
lesions at the
very lateral side,
then we most likely
are only damaging
the primary aferrin
fibers, you know,
the primary neurons,
right? So that
would cause
ipsilateral facial pain
and temperature
sensation deficit.
If the lesion is a
little more medial
at the pounds
level, then it might
damage the
contralateral fibers,
the tritaminothalamic
fibers, right?
And if that's the
case, then you
would have the
contralateral pain and
temperature deficit
on the face.
So if you have
any questions,
please reach out to me.
and this is again a
summary slide so make
sure you're able to
fill in the blanks
here's the answer here
is my answer if you
have any issues and
questions confused
about anything please
let me know we can
definitely set up some
sessions you could
come to my review
sessions to clarify these
Now pause the
video to see if
you can solve
this question.
And here's the answer.
Hopefully you
got it correctly.
Question number
three. Now pause
the video please
and see if
you can answer
this question.
Here's the
answer. Hopefully
you got it correctly.
Okay, so this is a
pretty complex case.
This is actually
Brown-Sacar syndrome.
So by now, again,
you should be able to
figure out what the
deficits are, you know,
which side of the
lesion this type of
presentations are
generated and why exactly
you're seeing all
of these deficits.
So I have an explanation
in the next slide.
basically because
of the loss of the
sensations of this one
entire segment so you
would expect to have
this damage to the
entire side of the
spinal cord we call
it hemi section of
the spinal cord and
because this is a lower
body that experiencing
all the deficit
so the damage has
to be at the lumbar
spinal cord, right?
And then correlating
to all these losses,
you know, all these
sensory losses,
we are able to,
we should be able
to figure out
these losses are on
the left side of
the spinal cord.
And, you know,
we have all these
numbers correlating
with the lesions.
So go over these
one by one.
see if it makes
sense to you.
That concluded
today's lecture.
So make sure you
understand all
of those information
and be able
to fill out the
answer sheet.
And I know these
are pretty hard
materials, especially
the lateralization of
the lesions versus
deficits. If you
have difficulty, make
sure you reach out
to me and we can
make appointment and
talk individually.
If you have any
general feedback,
comments, suggestions,
send this along
using this
link. Thank
you very much.